[موسيقى]
فيما تغريك الرمال البيضاء على شواطئ
جزيره بورتوريكو بان عطله سنويه ستكون
الاجمل هنا فان وقوعها على البحر الكاريبي
يجعلها احد اسوا الاماكن الاستقرارا فلا
تكاد تنتهي عاصفه حتى تضرب الاخرى اما
الاسوء فحدث عندما اغرق اعصار ماريا
الجزيره باكملها وتسبب في ماساه انسانيه
كبرى فماذا حدث
في صبيحه العشرين من سبتمبر للعام 2017
كان الجزيره بورتوريكو على موعد مع اعصار
المدمر اعتبر الاكثر عنفا منذ 80 عاما
بدا الاعصار بزوبعه على طول الجانب
الشمالي من جزر البحر الكاريبي ثم وصل الى
اليابسه في جزيرتي دومينيكا وبورتوريكو
كانت دومانيك البالغ عدد سكانها 71000 اول
موقع هبوط لماريه وصنف حينها بالفئه
الخامسه قبل ان ينتشر الى جزيره بورتوريكو
التي يبلغ عدد سكانها ثلاثه ملايين و
40000 سنه وتتراجع قوته الى الفئه الرابعه
بلغت سرعه الرياح 155 ميلا في الساعه
فكانت قادره على اقتلاع الاشجار واسقف
المنازل الخشبيه كما اسقطت محطات رصد
التقسيط والابراج الخلويه
انقطعت الكهرباء عن الجزيره بالكامل واصبح
الوصول الى المياه النظيفه والطعام مقيدا
بالنسبه الى معظم الناس دون سابق انذار
اضطر اكثر من 130,000 بورتوريكي لترك
منازلهم
حصدت الكارثه وارواح الاف من السكان وفيما
قال التقارير الرسميه ان القتلى تجاوز
الفا 400 شخص رجح تقارير مستقله ان اعداد
الضحايا كان اقرب الى ثلاثه الاف
فقمت الكارثه من معاناه الجزيره التي يقبع
اكثر من نصف سكانها تحت خط الفقر وتعاني
من مديونيه بمليارات الدولارات خصوصا ان
الحادثه تسببت في دمار نحو 80% من
المحاصيل الزراعيه وهو ما يعادل خساره 700
و80 مليون دولار
قدرت اضرار الاعصار بنحو 94 مليارا و 400
مليون دولار
وطلبت اكثر من مليون و 200 الف اسره
مساعدات اغاثيه واسكانيه
بالنسبه الى سكان الجزيره الكاريبيه التي
باتت احدى اراضي الولايات المتحده منذ ان
تنازلت عنها اسبانيا كانت هذه هي اقصى
كارثه انسانيه عرفها الناس هناك فمن لم
يفقد قريبا خسر بيته او مصدر قوته
[موسيقى]